my name is jim palmer i'm the chief
executive of waimakariri district
council
and my job this morning is just to emcee
the event on behalf of the cowboy
district historical society
i wish to thank you for coming along
today
to celebrate the opening of the museum
it's five years and one day that mother
nature changed the quiet boy
destroyed our museum
that was in the old courthouse
next to the police station
as well as uh
this the previous building to this route
hannifer
which made it the uneconomic to repair
we're ever so grateful to the
waimakariri district council for
including the museum in this magnificent
building through tanfa
the councillors were bold enough to see
the possibilities
of a new concept of a shared facility
we acknowledge and thank them for the
financial support to make this happen
additional support must also be
acknowledged and recognised for grants
received from the new zealand lotteries
481 1160
canterbury community trust 70 000
and our own contribution from the
district historical society of 130 000
this is another great day for cowboy and
its surrounding community
for the historic society that is so
important in our community and dare i
say it for the museum world in
canterbury and beyond
a museum is important for its collection
both on display and in this and in the
records typhoid's history is a history
that is worth celebrating and worth
preserving
uh communities and their history um
are totally intertwined
culturally occupies a special place
really it's quite
unique i think in canterbury's history
or certainly of the towns on the plains
it's not too far away from the great
power that it takes its name from which
was the center for naitahu but there's
also since then the woolen mill the
river port all led to carpool's
uniqueness amongst the towns on the
river
on the canberry plains and quite
different from the ashburtons the
rangioras the emblees of this
of canterbury so
it's a as i said a minute ago it's a
history that is worth celebrating and
worth preserving
this museum tells carpool's history in a
wonderful way and it gives me huge
amount of pleasure to be able to open it
today
i officially declare
the
museum
of the carpool and the carpool
historical society and of kaiapoi in
rural tanafa kaifu civic center
officially
you